today I will tell you about the project
to women solutions did with together
with cameos about automatic ad
categorization so what is our problem
one of the game use project is called a
drill and this is a tool that lets you
monitor and analyze online marketing
campaigns and it lets you answer
questions of the type and what
percentage of cart car ads were four
former cities for example and the data
here is completely made up so you know
don't take business knowledge out of
this but you know this is the type of
information you can get so maybe your
car producer and you want to monitor
your competition and you want to know
what percentage you know Volkswagen
carts were there last month out of all
ads about cars or maybe you would like
to know how many people sold and you I
found out this is this is valuable
knowledge for certain companies and how
how it works is that every ad gets a
brand assigned to it so for each other
you you want to know what is advertised
exactly currently there is some
automated solution that does not use
machine learning and there are there is
human work so human employees let me see
the ads and they say okay this is an
iPhone or this is a fridge and of course
the challenge is to replace this whole
replace the human work or part of it
with machine learning so let's try this
okay and can you tell me what is
advertised here this is a piece you go
to the website you turned off your ad
blocker for whatever reason and this is
what you see so can anyone tell me what
is advertised on this sorry Mercedes
Benz yeah that's nice first answer
because clearly there is a machine is on
the picture but in fact if you would
look at other mouths shirt there is in
tiny print written Mercedes Benzes or
snowed and the ad is actually not from
mercedes-benz but for a car dealer that
is located in so snow it that sells
Mercedes cars
so there is a different two different
things
mercedes-benz couldn't could have its
own ad but also a particular car dealer
can have their own ads and you need to
tell the difference so this is the first
type of problem we'll have with this
type of data is that it's not clear what
is the correct answer
now you cannot just say okay I see a
Mercedes this is a Mercedes Benz out so
let's try maybe another example I would
say and the answer is numer the car
dealer from Cessna bids and this is the
odd one that I saw when I turned off my
adblock er
and the text says shared extra cent for
the for non polished speakers here the
text is shared at present so can anyone
guess what's type of organization or and
yo ya charity this is the the type of
answer yeah it's very hard to guess this
answer because you don't know the list
of possible all possible answers so it's
pretty hard to get the correct answer
but the the answer is charity and on the
picture you know that there isn't
anything related to charity that much
right there Sant martí presents which
are very tasty but they have general
nothing to do with charity so not only
you know it could be confusing what
exactly's advertise you could also have
on the images things that are not
related to the the product being
advertised okay so the third one and the
final one of this this is egg yolk by
the way mmm
and the English text says one component
money properties speeds up burning fat
by 57% and lowers cholesterol this is
also now you can see on the Internet and
you also need to classify that
so maybe any guesses malware that that's
a good guess this time it's not malware
it's another type of scam this is the
weight loss drugs okay so there is whole
part of market that sells kind of not
working drugs that promise you weight
loss and there's nothing on this picture
that indicates this is so maybe that if
you analyze the text and then you can
guess that this is the by the way weight
loss but nothing on the picture tells
you mm-hmm and this could be about
weight loss like why the egg yolk I
don't know so what this is these are the
things you can see on the Internet okay
so what is the data here so first we
have the ads and the ads have many
possible channels they can have an image
and about 50% a bit more than 50% have
it so the I the image could be like the
charity ad we have seen already the ad
can have text and more ads have text and
the text could say share the croissant
and it could be separate thing from what
is written on the picture alright so
there is a picture that can have some
text but there is also a separate text
of the ad and there is also the link
that that leads you to the target
website so our website where we can
learn more about the product can maybe
buy a product so this is three types of
say input data that we have and then we
have a very big list of brands sorry
sorry about that so we have 30,000
brands per country mmm which range all
the possible things that can be
advertised on the internet so we have
foods and drinks like coca-cola we have
cars we have shops charity various
electronics like phone brands but also
phone
particular phone models maybe the new
iPhone 7 is you need to know is the this
art is particularly for iPhone 7 but
also smaller companies like the car
dealer from sus nodes and also the big
big brands like Allegro Facebook Google
so this list of brands is extremely
diverse not very related so the four
different industries you have different
depth of the categorization sometimes
you need to say okay this is immersed in
this car and sometimes you need to say
this is the particular model of a phone
so this is already looks like a very
hard problem and to make matters worse
you need to do this for seven countries
so there is France Germany Poland
Romania Russia Turkey and Ukraine
so not only different countries but
different alphabets and every country
has their own list of brands okay so
this looks very very hard hmm and how
how to solve this so the first first
maybe first in tank instinct is to use
deep learning
you know everybody is deep learning for
something for almost everyone but we
didn't go with deep learning and why not
it seems that this is the the intuitive
answer but there are problems with this
data set I already have shown you the
pictures and they are very diverse there
are different brands could have similar
images like the Mercedes could have the
Mercedes cars obviously but also the car
dealer can have the emergency this cars
there is not enough data for each
particular brand there are some brands
for each you will see only one ad maybe
only five ads in total there are like
five a few hundred ads daily categorized
by people so it's not really when you
have thirty thousand brands design few
hundred ad today is not enough okay and
you can really easily over fit so maybe
you see an ad of
fashion shop all right when there is a
lady in a dress and there is a name of
course of the store on the on the ad but
you know what makes it different from
other fashion shops with other ladies in
other dresses it's not clear or maybe
the ad that we have already seen
you know the car dealer from such
knowledge that uses that employees are
the mouse to do their advertising right
even if I can train my deep learning
model perfectly and it will learn
generalize greatly and it will learn
that other Mouse plasmids bands equals
methods masseuse novice you know next
month or next year this will change
right they will hire someone else and
this will completely break so this
analyzing images seems to be a very hard
way to solve this problem so it tried
something else and as I have shown I
have shown you very often have text on
the image and we already have some text
we already have text of the ad we
already we have the URL that links you
to target website so the idea is to
extract as much text and then try to do
the first idea is to take as much text
as you can and try to do something with
us so we could take the text of the ad
we could take the text from the target
website but we can also try to find and
identify logos in the picture
and we can find the text in a picture
using some OCR technic so and the end
result here would be to find the text do
Modi get ready and then do some
something more with it of course so what
we did to extract text from images we
used two techniques for two tools for
OCR with Google cultivation and
tesseract tesseract is an open source
tool library for extracting text from
images and the Google Cloud vision as
the Google clouds machine learning
solution and when you run this I'd say
through this it actually the Google
vision actually works perfectly so I
don't know if you can read the emergency
disbands to stop it on this image but
the Google cloud can mm well tesseract
doesn't do as well but there are some
cases where tesseract outperforms
disavow and maybe let's try one more
image the the charity that we tried and
then the Google cloud works quite well
but you know there are some
imperfections so there is a certain
drag-and-drop
website where you can just drag and drop
image and it will tell you what the
Google cloud finds and this is what he
found so it found the text correctly and
then it found a some random word that is
not there similar to the previous one so
we know where it came from a bit but it
is unclear and that the track does okay
job but also not perfect and for logo
and I said that will extract logos and
we use Google Cloud vision for this so
and this methods were not perfect
obviously and then like 50% of the ads
that have an image got something from
the Google cloud 20% got something from
the good logo from Google cloud and the
40% got some text from the tesseract
okay and now we have this text right we
took the add to the picture we got some
text extracted and what is the simplest
approach to the to the file to assigning
brands well we will just look for the
names of the brands it is the the first
idea right and when we do this we find
the Martell's ministers know is that we
want but also we find the mercedes-benz
that we don't really want right this is
not the correct answer
so we have
now I have the problem that we have some
possible candidates for correct grants
but we have false positives so we need a
model to say which one is correct so the
solution will be taken at extract text
and find candidates candidate brand
names and then predict which one is the
correct one
this will be the scheme of the solution
how do we find the candidates already
told you that we are looking for the
brand names in the text and here we
could you know use certain strategies to
find an exact matches find each word in
the text right we could use permutations
of words we can try some other tricks
like find important parts of the brand
names and look for them another type of
strategy is to look at similar ads from
the past
so maybe the ad have the same don't so
the ad have the target URL so maybe the
two ads have the same domain of the URL
right they all need to say source novice
dot mercedes-benz dot PL right if they
both have the same domain of the URL
then maybe they are of the same thing so
this is a possible source of the
candidates and maybe they have the same
title of target website or maybe some
element of the target website is the
same so that's how we find candidates
now we only need to predict which which
candidate is the right one and we have
our standard photo of Mercedes Benzes
know of it and we want to say the
correct for this car dealer and wrong
for the car company so we have classic
logistic regression problem mm-hmm and
how how to solve this so we build a
model using one of many available
algorithms what could be the features so
we have the candidate we
we have the odd right but we want to we
don't want to work early with text or
image data so we need to extract some
features and there are actually quite a
few we can calculate we can find the
branch of the country we can use the
branch of the candidate as a feature we
can also say how many candidates we have
for this ad right if this is the only
candidate this is probably a very good
candidate but if there are like 10
candidates well it's less clear we can
say how many times this candidate was
found right we have texts from many
sources so we have the text of the ad we
have text extracted from the image we
have text from the target website and
you know if the same candidate was found
from all three sources it's probably a
better candidate that just the thing
that appeared once so we also could have
which exact methods found this candidate
was found in the logos it's found by the
Google Cloud vision text extraction and
we can also look at the past and say how
many ads for this brand were we have
already seen right is this a big branch
it's a small branch is this something we
have never seen before
mm-hmm and also how often this candidate
was correct this is a candidate name
that appears very infrequently and every
time it appears it's the correct answer
this is a different situation that say
candidate like Facebook which can appear
in many many ads and will very rarely be
the right one okay and to do the
logistic regression we tried many
algorithms so the crowd favorite is the
boost like GBM which is an alternative
to e3 boost developed by Microsoft we
also tried just logistic regression from
a scale iron mmm we tried fill the word
factorization machines which also could
be used for this we tried the online
logistic regression
support vector machines and out of this
we picked one the that that worked the
best
okay and what else we could have done
because this was the this was what we
did and what what else could we tried so
we could have tried one versus rest
classification
even after we found the candidates we
could had tried to build a model for
each candidate for each brand but this
is a very this has very little chance to
work well because there are too many
models like for 30,000 brands you would
need to build 40,000 models and this
already seems like it will not work even
if you train them and say five minutes
it would take you many days to to train
and also there some brands are very rare
so they appear very early so there is
very it would be very hard to train the
model correctly for a particular brand
there is also a whole class of
algorithms called higher higher
he called classification where you use
some existing hierarchy so maybe you
would group the brands into food and
cars and iPhone and phones and then use
this hierarchy to make predictions and
we tried that and it didn't really work
well and I guess the problem for us was
that you need this good hierarchy to use
and we didn't we didn't really have that
have that there are also some approaches
that try to you know create a hierarchy
ad hoc from the data but they they also
didn't work well for us for this for
this particular problem
okay so the the summary of the of the
solution what are the advantages of this
so this is almost language agnostic that
the tesseract library that use is a bit
it uses depends on the language a bit
but other than that you just need a list
of brand names in this language that you
want to create a model for and you're
good to go this is from an LP point of
view this is simple matching patterns in
the text there is nothing complicated
here so it scales really well like you
want to do 30 countries that's not a
problem
mmm another one of this is that there is
one model per country hmm which is
important for putting this thing in
production right if we would have
thousand models per country that would
be problematic to blow in production and
the training is fast mmm most one thing
I didn't put here is that it is possible
for this algorithm to for this approach
to find the brand names it has never
seen if there is a new brand and you
have you haven't seen any ad for this
brand in the past it is possible for
this algorithm to to answer correctly it
is not easy and it's it will not always
work but it is possible if the ad just
has only this one candidate right this
is a new brand then our approach can can
find the correct candidate and give the
correct answer advantages so we didn't
use any
[Music]
complex NLP methods however one can
imagine that you could use some text
processing techniques for the to process
the text of the ads and then get better
better result to improve the algorithm
but of course you need to do this
probably for every language separately
you need to employ certain some domain
knowledge about the grammar of the
language and etc etc and there are some
brands that are very hard to find this
way so a brand charity well the name
charity will probably
not appear on the in the text of the art
anywhere so it's not very it's not
impossible but it is very hard to find
charity as a dancer and ideally what you
want to do what you want to have from
your machine learning system is that it
doesn't the cost does not depend on the
number of hats you categorize right and
here this is no not really true because
the Google services cost money they are
not very expensive but you break the
assumption that you have a model that is
you know costs the same for n number of
ads that you want mm-hmm and this this
complete solution is now used by a drill
in in their production mmm and that is
all I want to say if you would like to
work with us on similar projects talk
with me or email us at the jobsite mmm
solutions bail thank you
[Applause]
and the questions
when you mentioned at the beginning that
brands may be interested in the sort of
volume of ads that is say delivered to
their target audiences do you do you
have a system for that that's I guess
integrated with or is it something
something you're not looking at
yeah so say you know something is on the
front page of on it and something is on
a blog somewhere they would be weight
weighted differently so yes there is
some mechanism like that but I cannot
really talk about it and
[Applause]